be careful I was sleeping and I got bit
by a black widow is that true it really
happened yes I thought it was a brown
recluse which thank God it wasn't so I'm
sleeping thank God it wasn't I was just
the other deadliest spider I've never
heard of that spider it's called a brown
recluse yeah you've heard of it right
it's insanely dangerous I guess I'm the
idiot here yeah no your spider I have a
lot of plants okay right so you're
sleeping on your house yeah leapin it
was it was I was sleeping in a haunted
house yeah now you're sleeping and a
spider
jongseo invite you know so sleeping I
woke up and I go to get breakfast and
there's this red knot on my leg with
like a black Center and it was like
uh-huh
so then I do this don't do this by the
way a screen shot at it posted on
Facebook I'm like hey does anybody know
what this is all of a sudden everyone's
a doctor
through the look Judas bad they're like
I think that's a brown recluse and
somebody goes oh I think it's Black
Widow and then somebody goes I think
it's an ingrown hair and I was like I'm
gonna take it and grown hair I'm gonna
take that one so I try to tough it out
for a day the next day I just start
sweating I turned like bright red I go
to the ER at five in the morning doctors
like oh my god you got bit by a deadly
spider and I was like huh what do I do
she goes here you gotta get on
penicillin you got to like clean it and
get it all this stuff and I go one on
Facebook and it sounds an ingrown hair
she goes okay we go up the ER right now
so do you want to trust your doctor or
do you want to trust your friend from
third grade yeah I was like doctor yeah
so it went away and he went away that's
I've never I didn't think you could just
bet get bit by a spider just sleeping in
your bed that just seems very strange I
didn't I was horrified
ya know I'm just terrified I used to be
nice to spiders I would take them and
let them loose now it's this
yeah it's a war
you